what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation Greg here alone to watch
The Lone Survivor for the very first
time based off of the title and the
genre I can surmise some things that
this movie might be about but I really
uh I I don't even know if I've seen a
trailer for it so I'm excited to see it
so thank you for the request for it the
guys I know what you can do you can
leave a like that would just be very
please do it it helps it helps the video
secondly full length action watch along
as you sing it with your own copy are
available for our SS super sexy Rejects
at our patreon page and over there we
cover uh many shows and movies we're at
the same tier you get the option for
reaction highlights and watch along is
included really quick I wanted to give a
shout out to a YouTube channel that we
have recently partnered with and I
happen to be friends with the owner of
the channel so I was excited to partner
up with them that is a channel called
geek
g-i-q-u-e now what geek does is
essentially these one minute videos
usually of character origin stories or
other pop culture related content
beautiful part is it's from a wide
variety of creators the cool thing is
it's not only a great place to get get
some extra nerdy content if you yourself
are a Creator hoping to make a few extra
bucks you can join the geek community
and get paid to produce a one minute
short I myself have a video over there
talking about Nightwing koi John Dro has
two videos over there it'd be great if
you guys to subscribe to them because we
really want to get the spotlight on them
reason being is because it's a great
channel that encourages Community it's a
communal experience really and it's also
a solid place to help up and coming
creators as well and that's why I love
it so much we're thrilled to be part of
them thank you geek anyway let's watch
Lone Survivor which is not a geeky movie
or maybe I don't know
foreign God I cannot imagine being a
Navy SEAL make up your mind whether you
want to pass or choose to fail
all right now gentlemen I'm gonna
introduce y'all to something called not
being able to breathe
not being able to breathe
have you faced Near Death Christ
I'm at my limit so
that's it
hmm are these like the real people it's
based on
God the physical pain and mental
endurance
wow
what an opening
storm inside of us
I've heard many Team guys speak of this
a drive Survivor
a loud fight
the loudest coldest darkest most
unpleasant of the unpleasant fights
jeez
[Music]
e
[Music]
God damn what am I walking into right
now
just that insane level of risk and
commitment sacrifice you got to make
[Music]
I want two horses for my wedding present
I wonder if Mark Wahlberg personally
trained everyone in this cast man
it's got a good taste
how much oh
[Music]
damn do they even drink anything before
doing this I'd like a running buddy
Murphy by 1.1 barely
barely barely barely well I don't want
to be looking at him that close either
but he has to run his mouth about
beating him really
okay head shave is fair action oh he's
got great hair I could go both ways on
this he did lose but he was close and
you're Mike Murphy
Mike Murphy grab my Razor gun razor copy
that Red Wings a go tonight 1800.
still time to shave his head is he
capture and kill Ahmad Shah
bad guy senior Taliban Commander
responsible for killing Marines in
eastern Afghanistan as a tier one target
Shaw and his little earlobes
we're going to be moving up the back
side of this mountain here which is
going to offer great concealment I'm
estimating that it's going to take us
between three and four hours depending
upon the gradient Terrain to Ambitions
like this must be so scary maybe not for
them but I don't know I feel like they
know how to use fear
oh
use of deadly force is authorized
Jesus the movement is so we can get the
47s back here
ready to bring up for phase two once you
get eyes on Shaw I'm bringing up
tomorrow night's new guy presentation to
1400 today so that oh
congratulations buddy that guy's gonna
die isn't he I mean the movie's called
Lone Survivor so I imagine many people
we love will die she's got great taste I
trust her well what does she like rose
honeydew you better control that
situation it's very ongoing
huh
there's a bit of a Michael Bay quality
to the direction but not as
Sleek Mr Patton please
do they really have it people do this
release the Extended Cut I push more
Peter more sweeter and more completer
than any other Peter Pusher around I'm a
hard-bodied hairy chested root and
tootin shooting parachute and demolition
double cap crimping frog god damn
anything in life worth doing is worth
overdoing motivations for cowards I'm a
lover I'm a fighter I'm a UDT Navy SEAL
diver I can't imagine the camaraderie
and kinship reform
it's like people who truly become like
blood who aren't actually your blood
you know I'm not I'm not the man as well
versed to comment necessarily on what
what is real Navy SEAL training or
um tactics about how you proceed with a
mission but something about this feels
very much grounded in as much reality as
possible it feels like Rings authentic
is what I'm getting at
we'll be with you for the next six hours
have a nice walk Apollo 2-2 this is
Spartan zero one copy six hours six
hours
Spartan zero one is Miller that's a
great shot just the soldiers moving
through the Shadows so Spartan zero one
passes Miller
Spartan zero one yo is that Turtle Marky
Mark pulling his Entourage card here
Spartan zero one passes Heineken
what a trek
I wonder where they shot this movie
[ __ ] zero one yes he have the village
our boys are safe and secure for the day
team one back to bag room with me enjoy
your night sleep well enjoy yours
brother thanks Pete movies like this
make me wonder how much time the uh
actors spent with Navy Seals because
they they feel real to me
focus on me
Danny take our six
informed command of our new position
ax hi John
I really love the use of the atmosphere
you can really feel the weather the
overall environment
it's a lot more than 10 guys
it's a [ __ ] Army
red scarf
no weirdos oh
super freak that's Rick James [ __ ] huh
PID Colin Richard
I'm really curious to see how the action
scenes go now because everything feels
very authentic so far
sections I think the 27th that means if
I cut down the trees behind the stable I
get a discount for your horse do they
sell Arabic horses first of all it's not
Arabic of course okay it's Arabian horse
how much is an Arabic horse it's Arabian
horse dude how much is an Arabian horse
no less than 15 grand
it's a hell of a wedding present
is that redheaded bridesmaid that's
Melissa well is she coming she's a
bridesmaid yeah is she coming
she's a bridesmaid
[Laughter]
hero 9 30 we moved to high ground and
make columns
Marcus ax shut her down Deets you got
security like this they're taking their
job so serious but they're very
confident that everything's gonna be all
right
okay
can you get off the radio while you're
chewing
damn where did they film this as much as
you know some terror's about to go down
it's absolutely beautiful
please tell me turn the radio back on
hey can you see this
are they using the goats to like fish
out people
brother
do not make eye contact
yikes yikes
zero one over yeah
dude it's just intense we haven't even
really kicked off yet
Commander Christensen isn't here sir
yes that's correct sir I need you to
transfer me to bogum woulette talk
speed it up
speed it up
get me the skipper now
are you sleeping sir wake him up
Oak
Mike
Mike
oh it dropped oh you gotta be [ __ ]
me
why is Murphy calling on a sad phone no
idea we were good for a while but we
missed two windows now sir
[Music]
let's go through like I don't know what
the hell's going on
do not fire any guns wait I see it we
got three options
let him go hike up
probably be found in less than an hour
until we tie him up hike out they'll
probably be eaten by Wolves or freeze to
death not Jesus don't do that terminate
the compromise
make them hike with you for a while show
us down there we let them go we're
letting him go Mission fails
they can't kill these innocent people
they think this shit's gonna be private
huh it's gonna be out there for the
whole [ __ ] world CNN okay seals kill
kids that's the [ __ ] story foreign
this is the [ __ ] Navy and you're the
[ __ ] boss so you make the [ __ ]
call sir
oh damn that's a predicament I mean I
wouldn't our job is to stop Shaw
why do these men have the right to
dictate how we do our job they just
stumbled it's not a kid that's a soldier
that's death look at death they are
unarmed prisoners and the second that
they run down there we got 200 haji's on
our back 100 remarkable Brookside that
radio is fantastic cell phone to the
Taliban you just think it'll just be our
little secret huh
[Laughter]
oh God that kid's gonna make a run isn't
he we're gonna cut them loose and we're
gonna make this peak we're gonna call
for extract and we're going home Roger
that Roger Spartan zero one Spartan zero
one do you cop Fisher coffee coffee
coffee coffee coffee coffee they would
hate me in the military
how's it a tense ass debate
[Music]
should have killed him
foreign
[Music]
damn that look
did I make the right decision with
paranoia
this is a really great tracking shot
foreign
call I can't kill them but God damn does
that make this
a real predicament
oh my God
Spartan bases
what do you want to do
go home get in bed watch Anchor Man hey
man
let's fall back to that tree line wait
till Sundown if we can't make cons we're
walking home anyways gents let's get
some rest
damn
how can you possibly rest
God how much time has passed was like
they caught up so fast
Sam Penn Foster is so believable at
almost every role he does
[ __ ] man don't die
oh my God
you're about to get contact Jesus Christ
fast jeez looks like I bought a room
nope
negative we just got the opportunity to
make Health a strong contact with a
friend from the other side
yeah way to see the silver line
Jesus this is so scary is this how it
really went down
[Music]
and here we go
Marcus move
[Applause]
foreign
there are so many of them
this is Spartan zero
damn
ah oh man we've only just gotten started
too
contact 12 o'clock
ouch ouch
got us based on your story but
Peterborough does the right this really
cool at the same time
left is good I say again left is good
gripping
push right push right
oh my God
20090s
dude they're all getting gunned down
damn it you got crypto yeah
we're moving Roger that
oh
Jesus Christ
here
we're falling back you may fall off yeah
ah no way there are really oh my God
oh and they oh my goodness
ouch oh my God
foreign
there's been a lot of movies where
people are rolling down Hills and [ __ ]
that is the most
realistic version of that I've seen
oh that looks excruciating
we'll just drill just came down my mouth
God's looking out for us that's good
looking out for us
I hate to see him pissed get back behind
that rock man
that sucked
and shot me moving in the past Danny
living in the past damn that man
talented mentality God damn
oh it's his stuff oh man this is
Relentless this is relentless
damn
that's Danny you ain't good buddy
literally surviving on adrenaline
this is a nightmare
[Music]
damn it oh
oh boy this is really rough man
is a rough situation holy God
okay show me a pretty good bro
all right look at me oh yes
in the leg okay okay
let me see it
that's really bad keep it impact tight
all right
Afghanistan come here
oh boy
oh boy hey God damn dude he's losing his
goddamn mind
damn these actors are
phenomenal
[Music]
God damn it
thank you
it just keeps God
that's so painful
holy Christ it just doesn't end
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
reload man
come on dude
oh this is
gutter Richie Holy balls man
this is wild J bad talk Sergeant Hassler
oh God we need him immediately
Lieutenant I need your 10-digit grid
please hurry sir
thank you
get shot Jesus Christ
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
man there are the two who debated the
most
well good right
yeah we're solid
I actually really like the the way a lot
of the dialogues were done I need you to
make sure Cindy knows
how much I love her she knows and that I
died with my brothers
you're not dying next
We're Not Gonna God damn it
they still got like rocket launchers and
[ __ ] though
exactly what I was worried about
Jesus Christ
oh that's so sad
oh god he has just
serious Amanda thoughts are such a
captivating actor
oh man
you know it's called load Survivor Bros
kind of hoping to a couple of them might
make it out
massive kudos to the stunt team oh this
movie holy [ __ ]
you see any movement
I got nothing
oh boy
no way I can't believe it
they don't even know he's alive huh I
would love it if this movie just took
off
big left turn
and he just becomes this like shirtless
Action Hero
ES
that is so painful
okay
[ __ ] Jesus Christ
that mental resilience to overcome the
injuries
astonishing
okay
no way
it might as well take his hand dude
this happened holy [ __ ]
so show me where we are
stressful situation why do you help me
can I trust you
I'll play every Paragon there's an
American base located here give this to
them tell them where I am tell them
where I am okay
oh yeah
so we stayed there for five long years
oh [ __ ] cut your head off and send it to
you wow
whoa
this is
foreign
at least it's included that it's a
yeah
exactly that
there are some good people out there
nice
that's not
I need a knife
a knife you know a knife
they come in with a goat give me the
knife from my leg
God he must have such a headache
oh boy
this is so cool so gross
you gotta
cauterize something anything
America Texas
at some point you should say thank you
you know
are you doing this for me
it's so messed up
come back
yes
[Music]
god of the knife
foreign
I hope they do something for this
Village
don't
[Music]
just don't need to point the guns at the
Edison will give me crap for say [ __ ]
like that but I was like come on
you're watching gotta go he comes with
me that's not gonna happen sir these
guys will take care of you
wait wait
thank you oh finally yeah whatever the
goddamn thank you this whole time a part
of me will forever be up on that
mountain dead
as my brothers died there was a part of
me that lived
because of my brothers
yeah and I can never forget but no
matter how much it hurts how dark it
gets or how far you fall
[Music]
there we go
you are never out of the fight
Will Keep Us Together
all right
I'll be gonna be hero how we can be
heroes just for one day
I on a Marcus
just for one day
[Music]
well that doesn't look like it the
actors at all who portray them
and we
one day
oh that's the Marcus
his boy
[Music]
damn
that's cool
[Music]
oh no way
[Laughter]
oh that's great
okay wow what a uh what an experience
that was I I really enjoyed that film a
lot
I'm so tempted to just type away right
now like what was true about you know
what I might just do it I don't really
usually wait but I I you know I'm gonna
go over it I'll go over it after oh I'll
Reserve I'll look at it after uh because
I want to just focus on the movie itself
and take it on those merits right now uh
I really enjoyed it I thought that it
was a
a very
visceral
intense
nerve-wracking experience that
really felt like like I don't I I'm not
I've never been part of the military
I've only known some people who were in
the military
my wife is from Colorado there's a lot
of military people so I I can't say like
what is you know the realities of a
combat situation like these Navy sealmen
were presented with I can't say
however it feels like it was extremely
realistic in how it was depicted you
know really capturing the horrors of
that
uh and and the the story that's being
told here it's such an interesting one
because
you know I thought like all right yeah I
don't know anything about this film
before going in I hear Peter Berg Mark
Wahlberg as a war movie is probably
gonna be some action scenes cool you
know that's that's about all I could
really fathom I didn't really think too
much into it
but the the Catalyst for what leads into
the battle sequences I thought was a
very interesting moral dilemma to
present I mean I imagine that part is
true you know it's
easy to sweat because the one thing when
talking about true stories I never want
to seem like I'm sliding or being
disrespectful to the actual real life
Heroes of the people who are really
being depicted here uh you know I was
talking about so in terms of the movie
itself because that that debate that
they're having of what to do you know I
found myself in that moment going you
know like I'm on Mark Wahlberg's side
like don't don't kill these people but
then when to realize like oh [ __ ] that's
what's gonna lead into the the whole
movie with the violence and and the
combat and all that you're like oh crap
maybe no no I still made the right call
and it's that that moral dilemma of a
situation and I love how the
you know because obviously there's going
to be some moments there with it being a
movie that they're going to amp some
things up they're going to uh give a
little bit of extra salt on the drama
you know what I mean
but nothing can compost no matter what
extra like artistic flourishes they give
there's nothing that can really
unless you're there you know you can't
really feel the the true heroism
the harrowing nature of it you truly
can't feel it unless you're there so
sometimes they do like some other slow
motion stuff and whatever and there are
some sequences towards like the the
dialogue and certain scenes like the kid
with an I don't know if that's true or
not just the way it played to me in the
in the movie felt like a like a
Hollywood script move but whatever we're
in the finale it's a cathartic moment
you know when they when the kid hands
Mark Wahlberg the knife Marcus the knife
I don't know if that's true maybe it is
but the way it was at least captured
felt like a a film to me at that point
um but the real meat of this film the
real the the juice of this film is when
the battle kicks off because
one thing that I think really helped
elevate it and I was I was especially
taking note of it
um
amongst the actors because while this
movie's not the kind of film that has
this story of hey where Marcus is the
main guy and then he's gonna go on this
character Arc per se you know it's more
about an immediate situation and
capturing this this moment in time and
and the depiction of what a a fight like
this must be like
and I think uh allowing us to experience
this vicariously
you know I could see the one side of the
crowd I really don't know what people's
all I know is that I've heard it's a
good movie but I can imagine that with
the way people respond to movies today
uh even though this film's like eight
years old or something that maybe this
was like American propaganda or some
[ __ ] but I didn't really I didn't read
it like that when I was watching it uh
if anything it just gave me a further
appreciation for what you know the
soldiers put their lives on the line for
[ __ ] like this and just like I I'm not
man enough to deal with a situation like
this like that's this is real
sacrifice this is real hardship this is
this is life and death and
seeing what they're going through so
it's it's scary it's such a simple word
to use it's scary
and
I was just like shook up the whole time
while I was watching it and what I what
I loved was the dialogue in between
because as much as it's not like a
character art Journey
necessarily
you know because they're doing some like
basic setups with the characters showing
their past like a little bit like this
person and wants to get the Arabian
horse you know uh this this person's
wife wants to pick out tiles and stuff
we're not really going into the the
nitty-gritty of their backstories
but they still feel very lived in you
know so the performances I feel whatever
the back story is that you know maybe
another movie would really take the time
to really show you I
I didn't really need it I felt like the
actors themselves really brought that to
life like all of them they were all so
good this is one of Mark Wahlberg's best
performances I've ever seen Taylor
Kitsch I know is one of those actors who
randomly gets a lot of crap whenever I
say Mom I was like I don't
I've always liked it what he's done Ben
Foster is has lived in as ever Emil
Hirsch is also like everyone here uh as
part of the core unit was so good and I
really love the dialogue in between the
the
um the intense action scenes because
a lot of a lot of the times that's
that's where I felt like this movie
actually helped Elevate that quality of
having it feel real and authentic
because
I don't know there's just certain ways
of how certain dialogue in a typical
Hollywood movie would depict the some of
the way they they are shouting or the
way they are communicating with each
other
in a much more
because it while it is gripping and
intense in the way they're talking
there's there's something that feels so
natural about the way that they're
either
expressing how frustrated they are or
when they're complaining
um or when they do have to you know like
keep each other in check and and and and
you know keep moving forward because
that's the mentality these guys are
conditioned they're trained to be a you
know they're trained to be Warriors in
the battlefield
and this is
you know like this isn't a normal day
for them
at the end of the day though this is
like their life's this is what their
lifestyle has trained them for
so the interaction that they have and
the exchanges they have in between
whenever they get a tiny moment to
breathe to talk a little bit to each
other whether to be complaining whether
it be about mourning something whether
it be about uh we got to go do this next
or something
it was never like overly played up the
the exchanges felt so nuanced yet so
like this this feels like I'm listening
to real people in this real situation
right now and they're not just playing
intensity
it I I don't know if you guys know what
I'm getting at with it but that was
strangely something I was not expecting
out of this film and is one of the
absolute highlights of what I thought
made it feel that much more real was how
they interact with each other in between
you know the the shootouts and
everything like that it it helped
elevate it to another level that I
haven't quite seen in a war movie before
and I appreciate that because it's so
much about you know so much of what
they're trained for you know even
established in the beginning of this
film is is is is survival keep moving
forward you know as as much as they're
even the way they react to how they get
shot like a lot of movies when
characters get shot they always make a
big moment out of it right like there's
a big moment out of it but you can feel
this sense of purpose and adrenaline in
this drive this push to keep going
forward that
he's not saying that he gets shot and
they're just treating like it's another
day and it's like a casual way getting
shot like there's just the right amount
of emphasis on the pain of what they're
feeling but there's also the mix of
emotions of of of of adrenaline and and
fear uh running through them where
I can only imagine that when you're in a
situation like that you're not going to
take a moment to have a big Hollywood
dramatic moment of over getting shot
like you gotta you gotta just keep
[ __ ] going yet the pain and the
injuries
also felt very authentic like all that
when like the the falling down the hill
Peter bird didn't run down didn't he
likes to have people run this is that's
what's interesting though is because the
guy did the rundown he's done a lot of
other movies too but if I first thought
was the rundown and then falling down
Hills and [ __ ] but that is like funny
and I was like ooh cringy but it's like
fun cringe and and here you're like oh
my God this is like the most realistic
interpretation I've ever seen of people
falling now like no one could have just
died at any moment if they could snap
their neck to get a paralyzed or
something like that and and I think the
way the actors
played this it was such a physical
performance more than just actors who
were trained to portray Navy Seals the
so much of what they live and breathe
for is is depicted in the physicality
and and the the drainage they are
experiencing throughout this insane real
life obstacle they're dealing with right
now you know
and uh I loved it for that I thought it
was very very strong
and
so like the fact that they had the
photos and and everything with the uh
the village in Afghanistan which I did
appreciate that that was at least I I
like this being part of this I like
obviously it must be a true part of the
story but I like that it is in the film
because
you know it could have been really easy
to watch this film and then some people
could walk away I mean look everyone in
Afghanistan's bad but that's that's
where [ __ ] goes wrong in in real life
and I I like that we gotta have that
part of the inclusion of of the story
because you do see that hey
it's not ever there's a lot of shitty
terrible human beings out here in
America themselves so to get this other
side of it and to see that this was
someone who protected this real life
Marcus person uh was powerful there are
parts of how that was done
and maybe it's because I'm even less
knowledgeable about how a lot of that is
would go down in real life like I I
hmm I actually Wonder because I do like
this I do like the sequence when you
know he's first brought into the village
and he sees that one guys like are you
tell him that he's like trying to kill
him and blow and use the grenade to blow
him up like he's so paranoid and Mark
Wahlberg's performances are so good like
that felt very that rang very true to me
there are some qualities of how the
parts of the finale were executed where
it was the first time like they were
like the I was I was aware I was
watching a movie you know it wasn't like
when I was watching Schindler's List
where Schindler's List made me go I feel
like I'm
watching a documentary and I'm reminding
myself of watching a movie where here as
authentic as it was it it did feel like
I'm watching a movie yet in the finales
when I felt the most like it was a
Hollywood film
that's not to disregard anything that
was actually definitely based on real
life and whatnot it's what I'm talking
more about execution as a film more than
anything else you know and um
I don't want that to be the main
takeaway that people think that's my
main takeaway with it because it's not
overall I
I was really impressed with uh with the
handling of it you know Peter Berg's
Direction he's got he's he's got a knack
for the
I hear he doesn't do a great job with
mile 22 but what was that one movie with
Jennifer Garner and Jamie Foxx and uh
Jason Bateman I remember all the actors
can't remember the freaking title
Kingdom came on heaven heaven something
like that or is that the Orlando
Bloomfield Kingdom something I don't
know but there they had to hit a really
great again focusing on soldiers and
then it was like a half hour just like
non-stop action he's got a a great grip
on action scenes and I what I thought
was cool was while going for the
realistic like with the training and the
way these sequences are done and also a
wonderful handling of perspective in
those sequences
because you don't often really cut away
to the Taliban you're mainly just stuck
in the whatever limited skewed
perspectives that our soldiers our main
characters are dealing with
I I pre I appreciate a good lock on
perspective and
yet at the same time as as authentic as
it was you're like
salsa looks really cool this also looks
really badass you know and while I don't
I wouldn't go as far to say look you're
glorifying War violence that's not what
I'm saying
um I feel like Navy Seals there's some
badass dudes so if you're gonna
occasionally have a moment or two where
with the way you're capturing with the
direction of like badass
[ __ ] it they're Navy Seals they are
badasses so I'm gonna roll with it never
pulled me out of the movie if anything
has sucked me more into the film so yeah
guys I was uh I was thoroughly surprised
by how much I enjoyed this you know I I
heard Lone Survivor Mark Wahlberg I
thought it was just gonna be Mark over
and then coming to see like oh there's
all these other named actors that I'm
very much familiar with and it was it
was cool to see them here and I I really
bought Into The Ensemble as much as it's
called Lone Survivor and as much as they
they have that tease at the beginning
with Marcus
um you know being brought back uh on the
helicopter
I I still found myself going I hope I
hope maybe there's some so one of these
guys also survived because I like them
so much as a unit they feel like real
brothers in arms and
that's what I mean is it's one of those
films that drops that just sort of drops
you into something and it's really up to
the actors to portray something that
feels so real to the point where if
you're not getting all this like
Exposition that you can still buy into
it and still connect and for me I can
see a version of this where people might
walk away going I didn't really connect
with the characters but for me I did I I
really felt for the the main the main
core people is there someone I'm missing
on this thing
I don't think there is no like the main
core people on the team are really
connected with them and I thought they
were
I thought they were all excellent and
Mark Wahlberg did a a wonderful job and
I even like the the actors who are part
of the Afghanistan Village at the end
too
um all excellent work so also makeup
phenomenal makeup
holy [ __ ] and I love the use of practice
practical effects throughout as well
because it's a great use of sound design
and and great use of environment and
this takes a lot of staging you know so
much staging you got to do uh working in
working in a setting like that
but uh I but the the god what was I just
talking about excuse me guys still under
the weather
um
I was talking about the makeup I was
talking about the setting the sound
design
I don't remember bottom line is it all
oh yes the use of practical effects the
there's only a few moments like with the
helicopters and whatnot crashing that
that's when I was the only times I would
become like I'm aware that I am one sec
watching a you know I'm watching a movie
because of the CGI you know that's the
only times I was aware of the CGI but
but for the most part it looked like
they stuck to practical effects and
stunt men as much as possible I'm sure
some of the actual gunshots some some of
them from the guns and and whatever and
sort of dramatized moments were
definitely like they have to use CGI
like they would just have to but for the
most part I really loved how how uh
gripping and real it felt what would you
guys think about Lone Survivor leave
your thoughts down below be sure to
subscribe leave a like stick with us
throughout the new year last but not
least
Mark Leach my man listen dude I know
you've had uh keep bringing this up past
couple months that I know it to be true
and uh there's one thing I know it's not
going to live in denial
however it's been a few months since
some tragedy fell your way and
I think with everything you've been
dealing with like this is your chance to
prove how strong and resilient you could
be and be a Survivor right now would all
the [ __ ] you've had to deal with and
I think in the end when you do
experience some
some of the stuff that you've had to
endure lately
as time goes on as you overcome you do
come out a wiser stronger individual and
I really feel like
the opposite of everything that you've
dealt with because of the fact that you
are what's for the most part seems like
you're uh oh a self-aware individual you
sound like you have a good perspective
and it's just a solid head on your
shoulders overall
that the opposite of what you've
experienced in the latter part of 2022
I'm really hoping and praying for you
but
you're gonna experience a much more
positive opposite for most of 2023 but
remember that is up to you as how you
decide to move forward you know like
that's easier said than done but you
strike me as the kind of guy who's
willing to put in all the necessary work
to
find himself rooted
with better feet on the ground man so
thank you for being an amazing support
to us and for being a generous kind
human being and I really do hope 2023
ends up being more of the year that you
hope for buddy
talk with you soon
[Music]